ببطء لكن بثبات يمضي الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد الذي انطلق مطلع حزيران يونيو
الماضي شرقا وجنوبا فرغم الصعوبات على
الخطوط الروسيه المحصنه تحرز كيف مزيدا من
المكا
وتقواه بنجاح في اتجاه بخم في الشرق وتم
تحرير منطقه عين اندريفا
ومن الجدير بالذكر انه لم يتم انشاء اي
قوه هجوميه في هذه المنطقه وتقوم قواتنا
بتنفيذ عمليات الهجوم بالقوات المخصصه
للدفاع وخلال الاسبوع الماضي تم تحرير
كيلومترين مربعين في قطاع
باخم الجيش الاوكراني نشر مقطعا مصورا قال
انه لعمليه تمشيط بلده اندري مفكا بعد ان
استعاد سيطره قبل ذلك على بلده شفكا جنوب
مدينه بخ موت في اقليم دونباس شرقي البلاد
بينما يستمر تقدم القوات صوب بلده كوردو
مفكا على نفس المحور لكن عمل القوات
الاوكرانيه شرقا يواجه ضربات مكثفه من
الجيش الروسي الذي اعلن ان مدفعيته قصفت
تلك القوات في محور باخ موت والحقت بها
دمارا هائلا وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ذكرت في
تقريرها اليومي ان قواتها قصفت ايضا مواقع
تخزين في اوكرانيا لصواريخ ستورم شادو
وذخائر اليورانيوم المنظم وهما نوعان من
الاسلحه تلقته ما كيف من بريطانيا وبينما
تستمر على نحو شبه يومي الهجمات والهجمات
المضاده باستخدام المسيرات قالت السلطات
المواليه لروسيا في اقليم دونيسك معقل
الانفصاليين في شرق اوكرانيا ان غاره
اوكرانيه الحقت ضرارا بمبنى البلديه ومقر
الحكومه المحليه لكن دون اي خسائر
بشريه